tomorrow rather the clark county school  board is going to consider plans to try  and get some students back in the  classroom  you'll remember last year ccsd and its  largest teachers union did agree on a  tentative plan  well now they're proposing a smaller  campus specific model  the vote tomorrow will come as a new  report shows many students  are really struggling with distance  learning ccsd found  90 percent of schools assigned to more f  grades last semester than the year  before  11 percent of students who got an f in  the fall of 2020 we're getting a's and  b's in the fall of 2019  parents we spoke with aren't surprised  they say it's the lack of personal  interaction  there's moments in the classroom that no  one ever anticipates  that become teachable that kids might  learn a lot from  and all that's been taken away that  report on grading is part of tomorrow's  report to the ccsd school board